Tại trứng thành phố Xí Minh thành phố sự kiến đầu tư khoảng 1.5% tương đương bẩy tì đối lắm ý để phát triển Trung tâm tại chính khúc tế.
Trong đó, gia đình đầu cân mề sáng nghiên tì đồng để hoàn thiện hạt tần khu lỗi thủ thiêm, trong đó hàng yên tì đồng dành cho chủ sở cửa quan nhận nước.
Trung tâm tại chính khúc tế tại thành phố Xí Minh đặt mục tiêu khu tế là thú hút vốn đầu tư khúc tế nhất là giọng vốn sạy hạ.
Các tập đoàn tại chính đà Quốc gia đồng thời xe dựng hệ sinh thái tại chính tỏng diện của Minh Hàng Quốc tế, thì chương trứng khoảng 1 tài sản Quốc tế.
Hù lỗi dễ tích là chính phẩy hãy tà đặt tại thủ thiêm sẽ là nơi xe dựng trụ sở cửa quan khóa lý.
Giám sát, tài phán Trung tâm tại chính Quốc tế.
Hẹn thành phố Xí Minh đặc bước vào dễ đoạn tăng tốc trên khai nghĩ quý số 2,5 năm,
hành hủ trong 2.5 của khu hội về Trung tâm tại chính Quốc tế tại Việt Nam.
Trung tâm đặt tại thành phố Xí Minh có định hướng phát triển sản phẩm diên Việt,
phát vi tế mạnh của thành phố và hướng tới mục biêu trở thành một trong những Trung tâm tại chính Quốc tế.
Năng tâm vì thế của Việt Nam trong mạng lối tại chính tỏng cầu.